Stevie
Oh, hello, I'm pollen, and I like the 7 secrets of studying that language.
First of all, please spend enough time on the first one.The
second is that fun.Study in
a study method that you like
.  Ship English
What are you angry about? What kind of pronunciation do you have?
When I study words, I want to increase my consensus first
.
The number of words that I can understand is far greater than the number of words that I can use
If you can't
increase the number of interesting
words, you can't read the content, you can't understand what people are saying, and even if you study grammar, you still have a lot of those words.  After reading a lot of different sentences
or listening to various seedlings, I have that kind of experience.
Even if the grammar is correct, you can't say anything without words, and
you can understand what the other person is saying.
First of
all,
if you don't know the word, you don't understand the phrase, so our link system is designed
to help you learn that word, and the
most important action is
the link that saves the new word.  The
most important thing is to increase the number of words that you create and review repeatedly.
Of course, in the end, you have to use it,
but if you don't have words, you won't even be able to speak.
As for vocabulary, it's
not like you're going to memorize it right
away, so it's very
gradual, but the consensus is gradually increasing.
with Maeda